midi dans le quartier de la butte aux
cailles contrairement aux apparences ici
dans ce restaurant
c'est le coup de feu en cuisine tout le
monde s'affaire il faut emballer tout
ces petits plats faits maison destinée
au personnel soignant
car l'heure tourne et céline il va et
leurs amis doivent débuter leur tournée
des hôpitaux cinq jours sur sept depuis
près d'un mois ces restaurateurs ont mis
en place toute une chaîne de solidarité
pour offrir des repas aux soignants des
hôpitaux de la capitale
pour arriver à tenir le rythme il a
fallu s'organiser
8h30 même endroit céline sandrine il va
et julien tous associés passe en revue
les menus de la semaine en quatre ans
lundi office mollet la semaine
et puis ensuite on a juste en fonction
des quantités importantes de concevoir
des produits en soit on n'a pas toujours
ce qu'on veut on fait
cinquante repas par jour donc ça fait
donc cinq jours par semaine ça fait 250
ans pas pour pour le réfectoire you
pouvait sans abri ont fait une fois par
semaine avec chip cox et les chefs avec
les soignants ses cinquante repas est en
fait sur les hôpitaux 460 repas par
semaine donc ça fait quatre cent
soixante cinq ans a fait 760 euros par
semaine alors pour suivre la cadence les
quatre amis peuvent compter sur paolo
l'un des chefs qui vient cuisiner
bénévolement au menu aujourd'hui par pas
d'elle à la norme a commencé sur ce
combat probable une base bien sûr parler
termine avec des la déco retard et du
parmesan
on le sait dès des façons en allemagne
mais soyons tous les gens qui sont en
première ligne pour
tomates pourries business évidemment
et tout le monde met la main à la pâte à
commencer par barthélémy le fils de
céline c'est important je cuisine pour
ces gens là ont surtout dans le fort
difficile comme ça
que je suis fier
de cuisine
après un rapide coup d'oeil sur les
repas du jour est le conte pour
l'ambiance pasche les repas pour
or on
la première partie de la tournée débute
pour il va et céline premier arrêt chez
un ami restaurateur qui a accepté de
leur prêter main forte
[Musique]
aujourd'hui chose et après on a un bel
1500 juillet amiens 2
aghet essayé
de retenir une brigade de cuisine en
cage et c'est la catastrophe on a besoin
de faire quelque chose et je pense que
en ces temps que ces temps compliqués on
se doit de dd déjà nos fournisseurs nos
fournisseurs nous est enfin il ya cet
élan de celle d'arrêter un petit peu
parce que on se rend compte que c'est un
on est tous liés les uns aux lots aux
autres est aujourd'hui plutôt que se
morfondre à la maison on a décidé
d'aider les gens il faut ensuite aller
récupérer de précieuses denrées offertes
par un ami commerçant
trois collines m 1
aujourd'hui en plein de confinement se
rêvait tous les matins en se disant
qu'on va aller préparer à manger pour le
personnel soignant et pour les sans abri
ce tout d'un coup ça a du sens et c'est
vrai que
je pense que ça ça va rester au total et
six établissements parisiens bénéficient
des petits plats de l'équipe
chaque midi